hello everyone
welcome to yet another tech enthusiastic
video from simply learn
today we will learn about java lambda
expressions
so without further delay let us take a
dive into our agenda for today's session
first we will understand what exactly is
a lambda expression
why we need it and its syntax followed
by that
we will understand the term functional
interface
up next we will find how a lambda
expression
is a little different from regular
method that is
lambda versus method then the various
variable captures possible in java
lambda expression
and later the method references in java
lambda expressions
and finally we will wind up the session
by learning
the best practices in using the lambda
expressions in
java so i hope i made myself clear with
the agenda
now let us quickly get started with the
first question
what is a lambda expression
now lambda expressions were not there
along with
java since the beginning there were an
update to java
since its eighth version lambda
expressions are basically
an advanced method of writing methods to
be simple
these lambda expressions can be used
inside a previously
written method this approach reduces the
code length and
improvises performance to a greater
extent so
we can define it as follows a lambda
expression
is a short block of code that takes in
parameters and returns a value
lambda expressions are similar to
methods but they do not need a name
and they can be implemented right inside
the body of any method
now your very first question is we had
methods
then why do we need a lambda expression
that could replace the conventional
method
so that's exactly where we understand
the need for lambda expressions
now lambda expressions are having some
impeccable features
they are capable of converting huge
block of code into a tiny
argument now how cool is that now coming
back into methods
when we need to create a method we need
to make sure that it belongs to a
certain class
no matter that we can create a method
without having to belong to any class
but that would be just
excess lines of course lying in your
project
but when it comes to lambda expressions
a lambda function can be created
without belonging to any class and
finally
land by expressions can be passed around
as if it was an object and can be
executed on demand
now how do the verb and what is the
functional interface
these will be the next questions before
that we shall understand the syntax of
lambda expressions then
slowly we will move ahead into the
functional interface
so followed by the need of lambda
expressions we enter the syntax of
lambda expressions
now the syntax of lambda expressions is
something which is shown on the screen
right now
now you might be wondering if lambda
expressions have three different
syntaxes
no it's actually based on the number of
parameters we use
so the first syntax belongs to the first
type where we have absolutely zero
parameters
the second one is preferred when we had
one
single parameter and the last one
is preferred when we had multiple
parameters
now do not worry about the number of
parameters used we shall execute
examples based on each and every type of
them to have a better understanding of
each type now we enter the most
important topic
of today's discussion which is the
functional interface
in lambda expressions functional
interface serves as a data type for the
lambda expressions
it is represented by the annotation
called
functional interface it mainly consists
of
an unimplemented abstract method
and when an interface is represented
using
functional interface annotation or
basically a functional interface can
never have
more than one unimplemented abstract
method inside it
if you try to declare more than one then
automatically
we will face a compiler error so the
function interface can be defined as
follows
a functional interface in java is an
interface that contains only a single
unimplemented abstract method a
functional interface can contain
default and static methods which do not
have
an implementation in addition to a
single unimplemented method
now that we have a theoretical
understanding of a functional interface
let us get into the practical mode where
we will try to execute some different
examples based on functional interfaces
and lambda expressions i hope so far
everything was clear
now let's begin with the practical
session
now we are in the practical mode and we
are on eclipse now let's quickly create
a project
let's name our project as lambda
just finish it
and done now we are having a lambda
project over here and this is our source
file
now let's quickly create a new package
so by default the name of the package is
same as the name of
project lambda so it's okay not a
problem let's just finish it
now let's create a new class
yeah so we have our
class here now let's quickly execute the
code
as you can see this particular program
on my screen
is an example for a button click
operation
so what exactly this program will do is
it'll create a button on my screen
and when i press that particular button
i'll be displaying a message called
hello world welcome to simply learn on
my console so this particular line on my
screen
is an example for lambda expression
where we are trying to execute a printf
statement using the lambda expression
syntax
now let's quickly try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see that i've got the button
over here
on my top left corner of the screen if i
just try to
press this button called click me i'll
be printing a message on my console
which is
hello world welcome to simply learn
let's try that again yeah
that's how it works now let's stop this
button
let's stop this program and continue
with the next example
so this particular example is based on
both
functional interface and also the lambda
expression
so you can see this particular code
segment is represented using
the annotation called functional
interface
so this is what i was talking about the
functional interface annotation which
represents a
code segment that has only one
unimplemented abstract method
now let's try to quickly execute this
program so this particular
code or program is nothing complicated
it's just trying to print the area of a
circle
we already have a pi value and we'll
just calculate the value
of the area of the given circle with a
certain radius
so the radius will be taken as an input
from this particular code segment here
now let's quickly try to execute this
so you can see the program got executed
and the console is asking for an input
for radius
now let's type in some random input
let's
input 15 as the radius now we should be
getting the area of
the circle with radius 15
so which is around 706.83 units
i did not mention the units here
let's consider as centimeters so this is
the square centimeter area of
the particular circle with radius 15.
now let's continue with the next type of
program now let us try to execute the
next example which is based on
the both function interface and a lambda
expression that has
zero parameters so we discussed this
before lambda expressions
are three types with zero parameters
single parameter and
multiple parameters so this example is
based on
zero parameters it doesn't have any
parameters it's just printing
one single message that is hello world
welcome to simply learn that's all
nothing more than that
now after this we'll try to execute
another example which is based on
single parameter now let's quickly run
this program and see the message
so there you go on the console we have
the message hello world welcome to
simply learn
now let's move ahead and try to execute
the next type
which is the single parameter one so now
you can see on my screen we have another
program which is based on
single parameter so what we're trying to
do is here just we're sending
a string of data which is the name of a
city
and we are just running through regex
and then we'll find if the
data given is valid or not so the city
name that we are passing here is new
york
now let's just quickly execute this
program
and there you go we have the output the
value returned from lambda is true so
the function that is info dot
matches worked perfectly now let's
quickly get into the next type of
example where we have
multiple parameters so as you can see on
my screen we have a small
and simple example for multiple
parameters lambda expression
so the multiple parameters that we will
be passing here are
the values of x and y and these x and y
will be multiplicated with each other
so that we'll be getting a product of
these two numbers
now we have the functional interface
which has one unimplemented method which
is the float multiplication
now let's quickly try to execute this
and see the output
so the value is passed by 100 200 and
205
so the respective product of those two
or those four numbers is being given
here
so the product of 2 and 5 is 10 and the
product of 100 and 200 is to
20 000 so that's how the program for
multiple parameters in a lambda
expression work
now let's try to continue with our next
example where we will try to print
multiple elements present in a list or
an array using for each
loop as you can see on my screen we have
a small little simple program
which is a list and inside the list we
have a set of
names of fruits and we're just going to
print these names of this rules using
the forage loop
and inside the forage loop the control
will run through
a lambda expression which is simple
print statement
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
so you can see the program would
successfully executed and
the names of the roots have been printed
here
now let's try to execute one last
program based on lambda expressions
where we will try to
use filter operation over a collection
so as you can see we have our last
program on my screen
so in this particular program we have
three
variables which is the id of the bike
and the manufacturer name and on-road
price of that particular bike
so what we're going to do is we have
three particular variables here which is
yamaha bajaj and hero and the cost of
all the three bikes are different
so what we're going to do is apply the
filter operation
and filter out the bytes with on dot
cost which is greater than 80 000. so
this is how it should work now let's try
to quickly run this program
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the bikes
having price greater than 80 000 i've
been printed on my output console here
so with this let's continue with our
next topic so let us move ahead and
learn the major differences between
the lambda expressions and the methods
so the first difference between the
lambda expression and the method
is the lambda expression doesn't
specifically need a name
but whereas for a method name is
mandatory
and the next difference is lambda
expressions may or may not include
parameters we have already executed an
example
based on zero parameters and the third
difference is in a lambda expression
it does not have to return a type but in
the method
it specifically needs to have a return
type and the last difference between the
both
is lambda expression includes a body as
the main code segment
whereas on the other hand for a method
code body is just another code segment
of the program
so these were the major differences
between a lambda expression and a method
let us now enter into the next part
where we will understand the lambda
expressions in the form of an object
so as discussed in the features before
java lambda expression is essentially an
object you can assign a lambda
expression to a variable and pass it
around just
as a normal object moving ahead we have
variable captures
a java lambda expression is capable of
accessing variable stick led
outside the lambda function under
certain circumstances
java lambdas can capture the following
variables
they are the local variables instance
variables
and static variables each of these
variable captures will be
explained as follows first we will
understand
the local variables
java lambda can capture the value of
local variable
declared outside the lambda body now
look at this lambda expression that
implements
java lambda interface right now this
lambda expression is only referencing to
the parameter value
passed to it but we can change it
as you can see the lambda body now
references local variables
str which is declared outside the lambda
body
this is possible if and only if the
variable being referenced
is effectively final meaning it does not
change its value after being assigned
if the stl value had its value
changed later then the compiler would
complain about the reference to it
from inside the lambda body moving ahead
we have the instance variable capture
a lambda expression can also capture an
instance variable
in the object that creates the lambda
here is an example for that
notice that the reference to this dot
val
inside the lambda body this captures the
name of the instance variable of the
enclosing company id
object it is even possible to change the
value of the instance variable
after its capture and the value will be
reflected inside the lambda
the semantics of this is actually one of
the areas where java landlords differ
from anonymous implementations of
interfaces an anonymous interface
implementation can have its own instance
variables
that are referred via this interface
however
a lambda cannot have its own instance
variables so
this always points to the enclosing
object
next we have the last type of variable
capture which is the static variable
capture
a lambda expression can also capture the
static variables
the static variables are reachable from
everywhere in java application provided
the static variable is accessible that
is
scoped as public here is an example
that creates a lambda which references
the static variable inside the lambda
body
the value of a static variable is also
allowed to change
after the lambda has captured it again
the above class design is built
nonsensical
don't think too much about that the
class primarily serves to show you that
the lambda can
access static variables followed by the
variable captures
we have the method references
so method reference is used to refer
method of functional interface
it is compact and easy form of lambda
expression
each time when you are using lambda
expressions just to
refer a method you can replace your
lambda expression with a method
reference
so there are three types of method
references available in java lambda
expressions
those are reference to a static method
reference to an instance method
reference to a constructor now with this
we shall wind up our session by our last
topic which
is the best practices to be followed
while using a lambda expression
so these are the few best practices to
be followed while using
lambda expressions the first one is
prefer using standard functional
interfaces
functional interfaces which are gathered
in java.util.function package
satisfy most developers needs in
providing target types for lambda
expressions and
each method references each of these
interfaces is general and
abstract making them easy to adapt to
almost
any lambda expressions developers should
explore this package before creating a
new functional interface
followed by that we have use of
functional interface annotation
annotate your function interface with
functional interface
annotation at first this annotation
seems to be useless
even without it your interface will be
treated as
functional as long as it has just one
abstract method
but imagine a big project with several
interfaces
it's hard to control everything manually
an interface
which was designed to be functional
could accidentally be changed by adding
of another abstract method rendering it
usable as a functional interface
but by using the function interface
annotation the compiler will trigger an
error in response to any attempt to
break the predefined structure of
functional interface
so it is also very handy tool to make
your application architecture
easier to understand for other
developers so followed by that the next
best practice that you can follow
is to not overuse default methods and
functional interfaces
we can easily add default methods to the
functional interface
this is acceptable to the functional
interface contract as long as there is
only one abstract method declaration
so followed by that the next best
practice that you can follow is to
instantiate functional interfaces with
lambda expressions
the compiler will allow you to use an
inner class to instantiate a functional
interface
however this can lead to very verbose
code
so you should prefer using lambda
expressions and the final best practice
that you could follow is avoid
overloading methods with functional
interfaces as parameters
so with this we have come to an end of
this particular session
on java land by expressions if you have
any queries regarding this session then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below
and our expert team will have your
questions answered as soon as possible
till then thank you until next time
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here
you